Thank you. Good morning, everybody.
Hopefully everybody's having a great
show, uh, this
past few days, um,
we've chosen the topic here today about
thriving in the age of AI
agents,
and there's a reason that we, we chose that
topic, and, and we believe
that we're at a point where you have a choice
to make. And we also
believe that for you to thrive,
you actually have to reimagine
the way you work. And that's going to
be the basis um of the next
20 minutes.
Every time I speak to a CIO
they ask me one question.
What's different
about your offering?
And we think it's a great question,
but we actually think it's incomplete.
We actually think the question that people should ask
us is,
what's better?
Because
the road and the journey we're all on
is actually to be relevant
to our employees,
to our customers, and to our partners,
uh, for decades to come.
So we like to answer the question, what makes
us better,
not just what makes us different.
My name's Cahal McCarthy. I serve as the
chief strategy officer
at Core.AI. You're welcome to join
our booth 1753 a little bit
later,
but we believe that we're at a moment in time.
That AI agents and humans
can achieve something that if they continue
to act
independently that they will never
achieve, but if they join collectively,
they're going to deliver something really transformative,
not just automation
of our existing
processes.
Let me share one slide on who
core.AI is.
We build
enterprise AI agents. In fact, we
let you
build enterprise agents.
The kind that help organizations
orchestrate AI agents front
to back, end to end employee
experience
and customer experience, we help
companies on their journey not just to automate
but to transform at scale
and deliver meaningful outcomes.
So thriving in the new age of
AI agents over the last
two years,
we've all become a little different
in how we work.
We brought AI into
our personal lives and into our
professional lives.
We've added them
to our toolkit, our AI toolkit.
In fact,
many of us, at least on paper.
Um, our AI first companies,
um,
and, and that's where we're gonna poke a little bit
in the, in the next while
because we believe that many companies
are, while they're bringing AI into
their companies,
they're sprinkling.
It in an unstructured manner,
so you will get positive outcomes,
but it's not done in a coordinated,
compliance, fully observable
way. It's been an
interesting two years if you wind back the
clock over the last 24 months
and you look at how the narrative has
changed and emerged.
We started with significant optimism.
Billions of dollars have been invested.
The enthusiasm.
For advances
certainly emerged. And then about
4 or 5 months ago on the back of
a series of maybe MIT
articles,
we got buyer fatigue,
we got pilot purgatory,
we got news of experiments failing.
Um, but we also still believe at
core we're at a critical moment
of inflection,
and that inflection point is ahead of us.
Now, we get the privilege of talking to
hundreds of customers,
uh, every single day, every single
month across the globe.
And there's one comment that struck me
recently. I was in London at a dinner
and an executive said,
we're in. An automation
or not an automation we're a transformation
or transport
company first we're not an AI first
company and I thought what a
superpower
this executive knows what they're
doing
and then I actually felt maybe this is
their kryptonite.
Because they're catching themselves in
a trap
and the trap is just focusing
on the productivity frontier.
The productivity frontier is really
important.
It's important to your shareholders it's important to your
employees,
but it's not enough.
They're not challenging.
The business model.
In fact, here's a tactile board
that we have deployed at all
of our events over the past
year, whether it's in Mumbai, Dallas, New
York, and we ask people, how
are you thinking about AI
and everybody
irrespective of the city is saying how
do I become more competitive.
They're missing the point of AI.
AI is the
first tool in generations
that is going to allow us.
Innovate
our business it's going to allow us
transform
what we do. It's going to allow us build
new products and services, but
all of our attention has been
dominated by how do we
drive ROI again ROI is
important we deliver outcomes,
but how do you get yourself on that journey
to true transformation.
Every one of us as you walk around this
floor are going to look at
very similar tools,
rag search engine, LLMs,
SLMs, DLMs.
It's not necessarily
what you look at,
but it's how you look at them.
When Martin Luther King stood up,
he didn't say, I've got a project plan.
He said he had a dream.
When John Lennon wrote his song,
he wrote, Imagine.
Right? When JFK said let's go to the moon,
he said, we're going to do it not because it's easy,
but because it's hard.
So our opportunity
at this moment inflection is
not just to look at the tools,
but how do we look at our business
and what are the opportunities
that we see ahead.
So are you seeing a duck?
Are you seeing a rabbit?
We have all lived
through moments of
significant transformation.
We've all lived through the tech revolution.
The one thing we know
that happens when you have a revolution taking
place
is the points of friction.
Emerge
points of tension
emerge,
but it's the ones that transform their business
model
are the ones that realize the true
gains.
Now let's have a little bit of fun.
If you look at Ken Olsen,
who was the CEO of Digital
Equipment,
there exists no reason why
everybody should have a PC.
I'm not sure if everybody remembers Deck was a big company
once upon a time.
The cell phone.
Marty Cooper, director of research,
again, he believed that they will not
replace landlines,
and maybe this one is a little bit true, but
Jamie Dimon had a very strong point on,
on cryptocurrency.
Each one of these people
were the people that were closest
to the revolution.
But they stared at the world
through a lens that was tied
to their history.
It was tied to a world of optimization
of everything that they've built.
So let's just talk about the age of AI
agents. What does that actually mean
for us it's a shift.
It's truly a shift to autonomous.
And I encourage you all to get your definition
of what AI agents means to
you. It's not deterministic
chatbots.
That is your legacy world and still
when we speak to people,
they're looking at how do I make my chatbot
better,
OK?
These are providing us with
independent reasoning.
They can engage in multi-step
tasks.
So don't think just inside of your vertical
or your function
think cross functionally across your world,
and they can make decisions.
These are no longer the passive.
They're the autonomous doers.
They're the workflow operators,
and they're the intelligence amplifiers,
and that's a major decision for us all
to make.
How do we want our labor force to
show up?
Do we want our labor force,
our human labor force,
to be the commodity,
or do we want to make a choice right now
to amplify
through our agents and our our
digital agents and our humans to orchestrate
and work together?
We're at a point where we can choose
if we want to operate
in a golden age.
Or a dark age.
And I think I used the word sprinkled
earlier on in the presentation.
Many companies are sprinkling
AI across their departments for
many good reasons,
whether it's in the pursuit of
productivity gains to hit their end quarter
number.
Um, but they are compromising their business.
They're compromising the governance. They're compromising
their compliance.
Each one of these AI deployments
inside of each department are
point solutions, and we've all
lived through the generation of CRM
where we had HubSpot, Salesforce, Vantiv
operating across our business.
Each point.
Delivers point returns,
but they don't deliver the compounding
returns that you may be looking for.
So I challenge each one of you
to not just reflect on optimization,
but really how do you think about
transforming your business.
Think about AI against
the analogy of the autonomous.
Driving versus cruise control,
that's where we are.
You can reimagine not just the engine,
but you can reimagine an experience
that's adaptive,
that's that's contextual,
that can take you on elongated,
complex journeys,
not just maintain a speed on a highway
to get you
faster from A to B.
We have a different level of
power
available to us today.
We all grew up in this vertical world
with sign-ins,
access control, training
per system,
migrations to single
instance, data optimized
across. A certain ERP,
a HRM, a CRM,
the world we're living in today is
truly, truly different.
It will be a conversational AI
orchestration layer that your customers,
your partners,
and your employees can interface
across the systems of old
that we learned to.
Become friends with will become headless
systems.
We don't need to train our people
on them.
We don't need to have them interface
directly with them.
The time to proficiency for
our labor force is fundamentally different.
We're going to have to think of a world that is
more horizontal
and not vertical.
And that is the opportunity that sits ahead
of us.
So let's talk about thriving and thriving
to me means relevance,
relevance to your customers, your
employees,
and your partners.
The first question we see uh people ask
us is
how do I bring AI into my business?
And it's not always with the
technology. It starts with the
change management and the first thing
we encourage
at CR
is please ensure
that you've got leadership top down
support
and there's many ways you can equip
that that does not mean
there isn't a place for citizen development.
You can have bottoms up, but when the top
down support shows up,
provides you with the governance, the environment
to succeed,
change accelerates.
Obviously you need well governed data. Every
one of you here is probably familiar with,
with how to do that.
What we know is that AI thrives
when there's a room
and an environment created to
allow you experiment. Experimentation
needs to be encouraged.
Learning
is a competitive advantage.
Experimentation failure is
what will drive your business forward.
And then lastly, we deeply
encourage everybody to reflect on
an AI platform
with all of the observability and
the controls
to support your business. And guess
what?
That's what Core does.
We provide you with this
marketplace to rapidly
help you accelerate deployment,
multiple templates, hundreds
of them to get you going.
The second thing is we provide
an end to end.
Enterprise solution. Think
of your customer experience. Think
of your employee experience. Think
of your office front to back and middle,
and we can operate seamlessly
across each and every one of them.
We give you all of the tools
to make you successful.
Whether that's a low code, no code,
or perhaps a pro code if you wanna become
more sophisticated,
we give you all of the observability,
the compliance, and the governance,
and we're agnostic
to the integration.
If you're on AWS or some other platform,
bring it along,
bring your LLM, bring your SLM.
We will let your human beings thrive
by giving you all of these controls
with all of the connectors to
link into your pre-existing systems.
Let's go a little bit deeper
on each one of them.
The first offering we have inside of our platform
is AI for work,
and here you can search across silos
with our agentic rag and LLMs.
You can automate
your workflow with AI agents, and
most importantly, you can orchestrate.
And if you're an AWS shop, you can orchestrate
across Amazon, but we can also
take you outside of that environment.
We are deployed today
at scale in the most
complex
environments in the world.
And we're driving real measurable
business outcomes that
are transforming businesses
at scale,
delivering either customer satisfaction
results
or driving OPEC savings
or allowing these companies drive
some new business or productivity services.
AI for service is very
similar, but we're focused on the customer
experience
and this is where we leverage our truly agentic
capabilities to empower customers
to reinvent how they interact.
And that is a huge game changer. We're
not just focused on improving
better wait times, better response
times, but how do you react? We've got
46 channels that
allow
customers to interact directly
with your enterprise.
This is transforming. The customer
journey in many, many, many ways.
And finally AI for
process and this is the one
that gives you all of the controls
that you would need to transform
your businesses and businesses and
organizations are discovering
really new ways
to automate what they thought were
truly complex.
Experience that they thought could never
be automated,
um, zero touch IT
operations, triage
detection,
resolution of AI of
IT tickets. We're doing this
today at scale, and it's
companies like yours that have built
the workflows.
From very simplistic,
cross-departmental with an
orchestration layer that are
delivering amazing outcomes.
So let's think about
your employee of the future.
And we think about the employee, the human
employee,
a little bit like a mixing board.
They've got dozens of inputs.
They've got hundreds of adjustments
and thousands of possibilities
that they can make.
Now if you look at this,
a novice
will just see complexity.
But if you're a professional,
it's an instrument of creation.
You don't need
to be a songwriter.
to be the best instrument player.
To be a great
sound or mixing board person,
but this allows somebody to orchestrate
into something beautiful,
and that is the power of bringing your
AI agents with your human
agents
together to orchestrate work in
a very, very unique way.
So how do you measure success?
In the future
when you are thriving and we think
the way to measure success is
not
based on the number of AI agents
that you may have deployed.
It's not going to be based on the sophistication
of the LLMs. In fact, we
see many companies migrating now
for cost reasons or optimization
reasons to SLMs
don't participate in the arms
race.
That you see
in the media,
which is Company X has deployed
1 million AI agents.
Company X has chosen X
partner to embed
inside of their ecosystem.
Ask yourself,
what are the creative new revenue
streams
that my company can create?
What is the new opex model
What are the new services and products
that my company can create
that is
not only will make you different
but they're the questions that we
think that will allow you to
become better.
Thank you for taking the time to hear our story
today. If you'd like to join us, we're
down at booth 1753.
You'll get to see the demos of what
we have
live in the wild serving our customers
on a daily basis.
Thank you very much.